welcome everyone to see first series of
virtual talks on the theme science as
the exit strategy these talks are
intended to share how research from
across the Academy from computer science
population in public health to economics
and anthropology form the basis for
evidence informed decision making as
government's begin planning how best to
reopen shuttered societies and economies
in the wake of kovat 19 if you are not
familiar with us CFR is a Canadian based
global charitable organization that
convenes extraordinary minds to address
some of science and humanity's most
important and pressing questions like
many other organizations across the
globe CFR has pivoted quickly to take
action on kovat 19 launching new
projects and initiatives some of which
we are highlighting through this webinar
series my name is Kate Getty I am senior
director of research at CFR and it's my
true pleasure to introduce you today to
Professor Hendrik poinar Hendrik is
professor of anthropology at McMaster
University where he draws on his
training and molecular evolutionary
genetics and biological anthropology to
address questions the past pandemics in
particular he uses chemical and
molecular techniques within forensic
archaeological and paleontological
remains to ask questions such as which
path the gems are responsible for past
pandemics he's also a fellow in see far
as humans and the micro humans and the
microbiome program and he'll be sharing
with us today how knowledge of past
pandemics can inform our understanding
of the kovat 19 pandemic so Henrik to
start off her conversation I'd like to
ask you about the broad themes that
emerge in art depicting postponed
epidemics so for example looking at this
painting by antoine jean grow will be
coming up yeah that centers on napoleon
what role does historical art play and
how we
you and think about pandemics well so
first thanks for having me it's a
pleasure an honor to be part of this
talking point today and welcome to
everybody who's listening um yeah I mean
this is a great picking art art has
always been a powerful way for people to
reflect and comment on pandemics
socially politically and individually
yeah this it's a perfect tool art to
illustrate both human and political
responses to pandemics in the past and
probably not surprisingly to most of you
is tremendously relevant today there's
lots of important points in this you
know we could talk about the pay for
hours and hours but I'll try to minimize
those to a few of the important points
so first we put into context this is
painted by Anton John lawless in 1804
and there's type of Napoleon Bonaparte
visiting the plague stricken in Jaffa
this was part of Napoleon's Egyptian
campaign defied the Ottomans as he moved
across Egypt and in Syria and this this
takes place basically after the brutal
siege of Jaffa in 1799 and shortly
thereafter there was an outbreak of
bubonic plague and you know most of you
well know of course that plagues and war
go hand in hand and so if we think about
plague sort of bubonic plague an 18th
century
plague epidemic this is one of the last
ones recorded in in the Middle East in
Europe this is a descendant this
epidemic of the famous black death which
happened in 1346 and spread across
Europe killing about 50 million people
but I think importantly that that number
seems out of context unless you place it
into the overall mortality rate which is
something between 30 and 40 percent of
the total population which is you know
we think about the numbers today with
Kovan and and they are dramatic
nonetheless but I think in terms of the
context of the total population it was a
tremendous wipe of course to the
Europeans so here here Napoleon is
visiting his plague stricken soldiers
and he sits I think what's so
interesting is is there's really two
important points that I want to
illustrate in this
one of course as he sits dead center of
this painting of course we'll talk about
really the meaning of that in a second
the lights hitting him from the top and
of course it's it's drawn at the time
and the in an oriental framework which
was a very important part of of European
life there so the mystery of the Orient
at that time so I think the most
important narrative that it draws upon
is this idea of us versus them and this
is a typical narrative of epidemics we
always think about people those that are
sick and those that are healthy but this
case of course there's a double entendre
because those that are sick and you can
see at the center of the painting
pullian touching a sick soldier actually
touching a Bubo of the sick soldier
these soldiers are supposed to be his
French soldiers but they look very
similar to the to the soldiers at the
very front of the painting in the dark
sort of shadows which are also Arab
soldiers that are dying Ottoman soldiers
that are dying from the plague as well
and I think here here you have the
balance of the sick versus the healthy
but you also have this narrative of the
disease came from afar or came from away
and it describes this idea of what we
call European expection ilysm that the
Europeans could never themselves Harbor
disease it was always diseases coming
from the east and it's probably strange
so maybe not that we still have that
narrative playing out today right Cove
it is a Chinese disease or a Chinese
virus and that's no different than what
we saw here in fact our work actually on
the DNA of plague victims throughout
Europe throughout the second pandemic
show that actually that's not at all
true plague actually maintained itself
in local reservoirs and kept it emerging
so plague was a very European disease
even though the Europeans like to think
of themselves as being exceptional right
and so in this case the disease is
coming from the east it's coming from
people that don't know how to care for
themselves and take care for themselves
and so on and so forth and so I think
that's one of the important narratives
us-versus-them the second thing that I
think is is probably extremely relevant
today is that remember that this is a
propagate
the piece this was commissioned by
Napoleon in 1804 to be a piece that
would allow him to to rise as Emperor
right here wasn't emperor at this point
but he was hoping that this piece would
sort of help illuminate several of his
important points and you know Napoleon's
it's dead center we have the light
basically from the heavens highlighting
Napoleon and he's doing what we know
from the Bible of course Christ did with
lepers or the king during medieval times
would do with sick people which is
basically laying the hands upon the sick
and the attempts to heal them so but
it's also to illustrate to the people in
France that Napoleon was tremendously
brave that he would unloved himself
I mean how important dirt are glows in
the current though we think about but he
so he's taking off his glove and he's
actually touching the boo-boo and if we
can just zoom in on that illustration in
the next next image you can see that
that not only is he touching that but
look at his officers and his doctors who
are both behind him right they're
horrified which is the true
representation of as the painter knew
people who were scared out of their
minds about plague because plague had
repeatedly erupted in Europe for 400
years killing you know millions and
millions of people and so this doctor
behind them is is not surprisingly
donning a mask and of course that's a
that's a narrative theme that we have
repeatedly introduced today and actually
unfortunately back and forth right it
should have been wearing masks from the
beginning and the first we've got two
conflicting messages about how useful
those would be and so the doctor behind
him is saying
Napoleon you're nuts this is crazy but
of course as part of the propaganda
piece
it gives legitimacy of course to the
power and to his you know domineering
role that he has this this heavenly
godlike power that he can touch the sick
hopefully heal them and therefore
maintaining level above the common
people right so this power illustrating
this illustration is really a legitimacy
to continue ruling
[Music]
that's really interesting and that as
you've alluded to in your response there
is some of some of our current practices
and response to cook at 19 also are not
new you've talked about the wearing of
the mask but also maybe if we go to
another image that we have here from the
the 1918 flu we we can see that the the
sicker often isolated from the healthy
just as we're attempting to quarantine
those sick with the corona virus so I
mean what do tell us about the
relationship between on the one hand
scientific understandings and social
practices such as stigmatization matter
yeah there were two very important
points yeah I mean this is Kant Funston
Kansas with American soldiers that are
sick of influenza and of course the
scientific reason for quarantine of
course is to stammer quell the spread of
infection and this of course comes from
actually the earliest known quarantine
examples come from the city of Ragusa
which of course is modern-day Dubrovnik
and the Venetians closely thereafter
took it as Cuarenta quarantine you know
forty days of keeping a ship on these
small islands off the coast of Venice in
the hopes of quelling the disease but of
course you think about that forty days
on a ship I mean every time I think
about quote-on-quote on I think about
the poor people in the cruise ships
thinking how uncomfortable this is I
mean so the scientific reason of course
is to hope to keep the disease at bay
but of course there's political and
social motivation for doing this so they
this is the 1918 influenza epidemic and
no government at the time wanted to
acknowledge its presence rang on their
soil in fact all Western journalists in
Europe and in North America were banned
and fine and threatened with prison time
if they reported about it and there's
only one country that actually reported
freely on it and of course that was
Spain hence the name Spanish flu and so
this just illustrates again the the you
know the quarantine serves a political
purpose which is to make the sick not
visible to the rest of us and and so
quarantine actually you
we try to frame governments we'll try to
frame quarantine as being an important
part to protect to everybody and to help
those that are sick but of course it
never is it's never for those who need
it the most which are the sick is always
a way to protect the population from
those that are sick right so maybe
another way to look at that is the next
illustration which is yeah this is this
the TB patients in a sanatorium of
course you know many of you probably
know sanatorium just in your in your
back yards I mean there's one here in
Alton there's several across Toronto in
upstate New York and these were TB
patients and they were sent to to
sanatorium not out of the what I like to
call the Thomas Mann sort of room out
romantic alpine vision of oh it's gonna
be a beautiful day it's looking at these
Edelweiss and the Swiss Alps but rather
this this was a fear of the general
public and what it did cause it actually
caused social death because you were
completely isolated from your family
were isolated from your community you're
isolated from any culture that you had
and you were sent there basically to die
and so again quarantine serve both
political and social interests but
really they never end up serving those
who needed the most which are usually
the sick wow that's that's quite
striking a comment and to end on their
um well maybe then I'll transition to a
question that's in quite a different
vein which is the sefer group that
you're a part of the humans in the
microbiome program is interested in how
the microbes that live in an honest
affect our health and development
we're often commenting today on the the
negative impact that are overly or hyper
hygienic approaches are having on our
microbial diversity what role has
hygiene P plate and past pandemics yeah
yeah I mean that's really important
question given the the groups that I'm a
part of and fortunate to be a part of
human of the microbiome
I mean hiking if we look at the next
image hygiene has a long much longer
history
most of us appreciate made the earliest
accounts and these are actually written
in counselor of course so the 7th
century Greek goddess idea was also
later for Roman goddess as well
sanitation cleanliness and health and so
that's you know the this is quite old
our appreciation of you know cleanliness
is next to godliness right and for the
Romans has shown you in the illustration
loans all about controlling water water
was personal hygiene so think about the
Roman baths for instance but it was also
about removal of fetid water and sewage
and so and so forth so some of the
earliest sewers of course were Romans
they were exposed at some of the time
but still was the idea was to get rid of
waste and and I find it really
interesting because most of our sense of
what we when we think about the Middle
Ages and hygiene we think of them
you know Monty Python's Holy Grail right
she was the guy dragging a cart with
their bodies through the town and
there's nothing but feces everywhere and
dark and grim and muddy and those always
are perpetuated image of that but we
have evidence actually suggesting it
really wasn't like that in all his
situations yes and in impoverished parts
of the city it might have been in those
cases it really wasn't people took much
more care so you know I'd like say we've
probably had this disconnect with our
world since the rise of cities and and
hygiene has probably played a role in
that diminution of that microbiome over
a long time but really today there's
been an acceleration that destruction of
our microbial constituents in in a hyper
hygienic or overly and sanitized world
and that comes mostly because of our
fear of microbes right I mean all I have
to do is throw up some images of what
plague was like in the Middle Ages and
you talk about people you know 30% of
the population dying makes good sense
that people were you know really really
scared about microbes right right the
microbes became that is sort of the the
evil and feared thing certainly when
germ theory came about and we started
identifying a linking particular
bacteria with known infectious diseases
and so I think you know because of this
over hyper Sanitation that we go through
now with the corral
let me think of things about how
important gorilla is currently right
we've also at the same time that we've
sort of diminished our microbial
constituents which are our first line of
defense both orally and in the guidance
as a way to defend ourselves against
infection so I think you know it's it's
importantly as people in the group the
human of the micro group I've pointed
out there's a pendulum that swings back
and forth and in the times of active
infectious disease and pandemics hygiene
is exceptionally important washing your
hands making sure that if you come into
contact with something you wash your
clothes you try to wear a mask you try
to clean and you know things that enter
your house so that's an exceptionally
important point now but the problem with
it is how will we behave when the
pandemic is over right the behavior is
during the Black Death they they
continued for a long time thereafter
people had a hard time switching Bannock
because certainly in the case of Black
Death if you had these repeated
epidemics so you were never really
without infectious disease so will we
maintain this hyper sterilization that
we're going through now and increase it
actually more full because of this
epidemic or when we switch back to sort
of a more healthier way which is a
return to nature rather than continued
removal from nature you know as fearless
leader Bret Finley would say let them
eat dirt right return to the earth so
that we can use those microbes as a way
to stimulate our immune system in the
event that that would actually better
protect us from the next coming pandemic
it's interesting another question I have
and I'm thinking about this also just
looking at the the backdrop that you
have there the sort of the the don't
smoke are behind you I see you certainly
know as a scholar of pandemics that can
often be quite a dark a topic but I'm
wondering if he if it's possible to also
talk about how responses just certain
epidemics have shown something inspiring
that humanity you know yeah I think it's
always important I mean pandemics the
tendency to bring out the worst but then
also importantly bring out the best I
mean I think there's a there's a balance
that comes to the fear and loss
in a sense of community and it can
strengthen relationships between people
I can strengthen community relationships
it can strengthen your love for
particular individuals you know during
the Black Death one of the famous
engravings is death carrying off
children because there's such a high
mortality rate of infants and children
and so they're after children became
much more important not that they
weren't before but there was this much
more of a sense of preciousness with
children after the Black Death took so
many of them away and I you know I think
today about frontline workers I still
think about our elders who we've again
quarantined in in essence in a way and
you know I think of them in terms of
like the sanatorium movement and you
know how will elders be more precious in
the years to come because you know
they're now isolated we can't actually
have direct contact with them like my
parents are both elderly not yet in in
homes but are being isolated themselves
and we can't see or speak and talk to
them on a one-on-one basis out of
complete fear and so I think it's gonna
change our behavior and our perspective
on that I think you know importantly you
know I'm reminded every day of the
banging of the pots at seven o'clock for
the frontline workers we are and you
know all those important things I'm
thinking about the Italian singing on
their balconies and so I think you know
even though these are dark times and
they certainly passed epidemics it's
exceptionally dark times I think there's
a tremendous balance that comes with
some of the beauty that comes out of
individuals making tremendous signs of
appreciation and love and what can help
us carry us through these challenging
times well well thank you so much
Hendrick for sharing your insights with
us perhaps now I'm going to turn to some
of the questions that have come in from
our audience so one one that's come in
is why do so many diseases leading to
pandemics seem to come from animals yeah
well I mean most of the most of the
disease
in finish this diseases about 60 to 70
percent of them are zoonotic in origin
that is they jump from animal reservoirs
into humans in the case of playing of
course these were rodents rodents or
around a Carver you see a pestis and
they jump unfortunately by spillover
events that come from rodent infections
our Rhoda epidemics that then spill into
humans and these are just unfortunately
accidental emergences that happen when
humans come into close proximity right
so you think about humans in the Middle
Ages and the populations are growing and
all of a sudden you have an expansion
into a into a more natural land you
maybe you're farming that land and so
now you come into contact with these
rodents that then Harbor these pathogens
which are in some cases not infectious
to the rodents themselves and so then
they spill accidentally into humans and
we know that that's the same case of
course with Kovan these are our bad
origin most likely but it seems like
they can infect a wide host of other
mammalian animals so there's talk of
course with the Pangolin so that it
seems to be a really interesting
evolutionary link between the Pangolin
and the bat and now they're talking
about of course ferrets and other it
felines and so on and so forth so a
large percentage of these infectious
agents are still out there in fact I
mean I think the latest estimates are
about 2 percent of the known variome has
actually been sequenced so there's a lot
of viruses RNA viruses out there that
are sitting in in host and of course as
we continue in encroach on these
landscapes we're gonna run into these
spillover events repeatedly another
question that come picks up on that
point that's come in and is how how then
do we convince people that not all
microbes are bad well I think you know I
think you know that the group that lucky
to be a part of us is one way to do that
I mean we have to educate the young and
I see it happening all the time you know
we talk about the important bacteria in
yogurt the important bacteria in cheese
and milk and and how eating healthy
vegetables can add you know important
fiber to your in your gut contains up
is microbes and so I think we need to
you know we've really talked about
individual bacteria of the course of
history that have had massive effects on
mortality rates but we need to talk in
the same way about all these great
bacteria lactobacillus was for example
that are important bacteria from from
milk dairy based products that play a
tremendous role in providing important
neurotransmitters and communicate back
and forth with our brains and can
modulate depression and anxiety and in
some cases even obesity so there's a
tremendous I think that the more we sort
of open up this fantastic microbial box
that is our system our followed by aunt
as it's placed you know we are not just
human cells worms or more bacterial and
viral and fungal cells than we are human
which is an interesting way to think
about it and as that becomes
increasingly more and better known I
think people really appreciate there's a
fine balance between those that are
really problematic which it's really a
handful you know it's a very small
number of infectious agents so far that
have really caused the kind of epidemics
that I sort of study in the past the
bulk of them do very little to us if
anything at all and a huge host of them
that we live with are our symptoms
helpful commensals that help us digest
foods and fight infection and so on and
so forth that's traffic in it there and
almost distracted by all these questions
I think this conversation could go on
for quite a long time I'm having to
choose amongst terrific questions here
but um maybe oh that's one of the ones
that just just came in but it's the
question is that it seems that with most
plagues there are great inequalities and
how they affect different groups and
populations in society can can you think
of examples where societies have handled
these diseases more equitably well
that's a very good question
you know epidemics and pandemics are an
immediate window onto the state of
affairs of any particular country County
nation however you want to divide it I
mean and they show they immediately
bring to the surface to the inequity
that
this within societies so your question
it was is there can I think of a case
where they dealt more that's a really
really good question off the top of my
head unfortunately no I mean the one
thing economics do is they immediately
highlight government failures and so in
any case where you have dramatic
inequality of wealth for example and
AMEX always always affect those of lower
socioeconomic income much harder than
they do the other ones those that aren't
in those situations because they don't
have access to proper food and nutrition
and so they're you know compromise they
don't have access to clean water or we
know that's big problem today across in
our country right with indigenous
populations in the north they don't have
access to proper health care and
medicines so this is a question I'll
take with me after this there they think
hard about because it certainly doesn't
come to mind immediately most of the
cases that I can think about it the past
always shows dramatic inequity across
populations unfortunately sadly it's
still true today in the current epidemic
again highlighting all these social
issues once again thank you for that
response unfortunately we've only got
about two minutes left so I might try to
squeeze in one last question if you're
interested and it relates more to your
your own research which involves
recovering DNA from from centuries ago
and someone is asking what those ancient
DNA tell us that ancient pathogens and
pandemics yeah that's that's very good
questions well so I think one of the
important things the first thing I think
is really important is that can help
really sigh the etiology of a particular
infectious epidemic yeah and that might
seem like that's sort of an easy answer
but you have to understand that in the
absence
you know vacuum of an identifying agent
blame can go in all sorts of different
directions so remember during the Black
Death
and during that absence of knowledge of
what that was people of course blamed
everybody you can imagine that sense of
prostitutes Jews everybody was either
burned at the stake or tortured in this
ways that we don't want to get into a
talk about um
and still you even think that hendrik
that's something of the past well now
think about HIV right for the longest
time the HIV was wasn't even associated
as being a potential virus and because
it happened to be in a disenfranchised
community in the homosexual community in
San Francisco in New York in Montreal it
was really stigmatized as unimportant
and insignificant and when that identity
became where it was really significant
so I think one of the things is really
that that immediate identity of what
those infectious agents were in the past
the second thing of course is do we
understand if its behavior in the past
is different to how it might act still
today or if re-emergence has continued
to happen you know
how can we actually modulate our
behavior translated be depending upon
that are there things that we can do to
actually contact and trace and be aware
screen for example if we know the
evolutionary history of that the third
thing of course is it talks about an
evolutionary to send in the agent
infectious agents and the contemporary
ones and I think that play is also an
important role in understanding its
evolutionary trajectory where is it
going from here where has it been I
think we're running out of time so I
could go on it's been really really
fantastic Hendrik thank you so much and
I'd also really like to thank everyone
for joining in and giving us such
terrific questions TIFF you do so for
everyone please visit our website
seabirds CA to find out more but the
series will have a few more talks coming
up and we also have previous record of
tops available there but yes just in
signing off I'd like to thank you again
Hendrick and wish you all a great
afternoon thank you all right